how are you doing sir
i'm doing all right how's it going uh
it's going very well and i will tell you
why
uh i read that you are also a tom brady
fan just like me
hold on i don't know if i should spin my
camera but i have a gigantic painting of
him right there
i also have this uh this signed box
helmet from
uh tom brady and rob gronkowski uh i've
got
um three other signed helmets upstairs
so yes
i'm a little bit of a fan so i have to
ask you about the
the helmet um did okay how did you get
that is that like something like someone
got for you did you buy it
um i i think there was like a day where
there was like a limited number of them
on a on a site i just i bought it
i was just like this matters to me
this matters too much to me i grew up
near the stadium
so i was following the patriots this is
not where i met this interview go but
i'm not i'm a big tom brady fan and i'm
also rooting for him on the books i just
think he's a class act
i i fully agree with that i think anyone
that was like
oh we shouldn't support him because he's
on a new team it just
is very that was stupid that was
disrespectful to everything he did for
that team
oh please i'm a huge patriots fan but no
he's he's
amazing he's the goat i'm with you on
that one
i'm with you on that one so i can do the
whole interview just on tom brady but
jumping into it so when you got asked to
do this
uh project were you sort of like yeah
this is an episode of punk and i'm not
falling for it
um i didn't necessarily think that but
it definitely didn't make
sense like i was like why i'm a weird
australian dude
sitting in his spare bedroom i'm like
why why wha what do you mean hollywood
brian reynolds
big time directors what do you mean i
was confused but once like i had the
meeting with them
and they explained it and that their
thought process
uh it all did make a lot of sense sure i
i
am listen you're very successful at what
you do and i think a lot of people might
not realize what goes on behind the
scenes
i'm curious what do you think actually
would surprise people to learn
about being like a live streamer being a
professional gamer
i have spent probably eight times more
like you know in terms of total time
editing than i ever have filming or
playing games in the last six and a half
years
like i think people don't think you just
like oh it's a 10 minute video dude he
plays games for 10 minutes
adds a couple cuts or sends it off to
another it's like i edit my own videos
like
i come up with my own ideas i do my own
filming like i do the whole process
and you know those times where i was
doing like you know five or six videos a
week
when i was in my real big growth stage
and i was sleeping three or four hours a
night sometimes
like you know like i'm lucky i had such
a loving mother that could put up with
my crap and i was still living at my
parents house
and she'd like cook for me and clean up
after me and stuff and i was so lucky to
have that
because i was a zombie i was a zombie
doing that so i think that's my biggest
thing is like people think it's easy
and obviously you know we are very lucky
to do it because we're passionate about
what we do every day you know there can
be a lot of money in and stuff
but that doesn't mean it's easy if that
makes sense like i was a construction
worker before this
and that was definitely a lot easier so
yeah you know something i have a buddy
who does construction and i try
explaining to people i'm like
to me that is uh like i i don't want to
say a real job
but like if you're standing in the sun
like doing what you got i mean that's a
completely different beast
yeah yeah like so i think there's just
different challenges in every career
path i think
and i don't blame people for thinking
those things i thought the same thing
before i got into it
um it's just yeah it does surprise you
how much actual work
goes into everything and to getting
everything right especially once you get
to a bigger and bigger scale
one of the things that i love about
video games is every year it seems like
the technology gets better and better
the games get more immersive what do you
think games are on like the cusp of
being able to do
that they currently can't do what are
you looking forward to i'm looking
forward to when
we can have a full vr experience which
in a lot of ways you kind of already can
like even those games like it's kind of
happening in the background
but i have a friend who has made a lot
of vr videos so i used to sort of see
what he
would do and just the way you can
interact in those worlds now
and you know the future of like you know
all of that
and maybe that's still 20 years away for
it to be properly perfect but i think
that's just going to change
every immersion immersive experience
that we have
um in terms of how we see movies and how
we see entertainment productions
how we see games all of that i think
it's all going to change like with
virtual reality
i i completely completely agree
what's a game that you wish more people
knew about
i've i've been asked this a couple of
times i wish i had an
answer just because i have slacked so
much in like the indie scene in the last
couple years focusing mostly just on the
big projects of like the big games
um like i i don't know that's a tough
one like i've been
i think on the big scale i think games
have been slacking a lot lately there
hasn't really been that big game that
sort of
you know captured people lately and i
definitely haven't had my finger on the
indie scene so i don't know if i
necessarily have an answer for that
um i still play runescape every now and
then
old school runescape so if you know more
people could play that that'd be nice
well that that's another thing it's like
you obviously do you get to play
games like do you want to play games for
fun at this point is it
is it hard or like once you sign off
you're like i'm done
i don't want to do stuff it definitely
corrupts your experience of playing
games for fun mostly not because you
don't enjoy them
but because you feel guilty for enjoying
them you know you feel guilty for not
working like if i'm spending time
playing a game it's like
could i be doing something that's
content related right now uh could i be
doing something for
like to could i be editing could i be
doing something else because you could
like that's the thing when i was talking
about
like you know this being easier from the
outside than it is
like for us in reality it's our entire
existence
like you don't switch off when you do
this so like you can always be doing
more you can always be pushing further
ahead you can always be doing a bigger
video a bigger project
so yeah it's been a while i think i've
been playing a couple games recently
with my sister and my girlfriend
um so that's been a nice change but for
most of the last six and a half years no
like i'll i can play runescape because
you can do that at like a lot of that
afk
and just click once every 10 minutes so
that's that's like why that's quite a
good game for me but um
otherwise no i haven't really got to
enjoy too much
i completely understand what you're
saying same thing with collider
um it's a tough gig uh thank you so much
for your time man
and uh thank you congrats on being part
of such a cool movie i appreciate that
thank you very much